members take your
[Music]
seats
the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne moves the
house adjourned from the session of May
5th 2022 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes haveen and the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by house chaplain Reverend Bob
Stewart pastor of St Paul's un United
Methodist Church in
Manchester thank you Mr Speaker good
morning
everyone you know a while back I
received a story about a visiting Pastor
who attended a a men's breakfast in the
middle of a rural farming area of the
country the group had asked the an old
farmer decked out in his bibbed
overhauls to say grace for the morning
breakfast Lord I hate
buttermilk the farmer
began the visiting Pastor opened one eye
to glance at the farmer and wondered
where this was
going the farmer loudly proclaimed Lord
I hate
lard now the pastor was growing
concerned without Miss seen a beat the
farmer continued and Lord you know I
don't much care for raw white
flower the pastor once again opened an
eye to glance around the room and saw
that he wasn't the only one feeling
uncomfortable then the farmer
added but Lord when you mix them all
together and bake them I do love warm
biscuits so Lord when things come up
that we don't like when life gets hard
when we don't understand what you're
saying to us help us to just
relax pause and wait until you are done
mixing it will probably be even better
than
biscuits let us pray oh gracious God
everywhere we turn we hear or see the
tent ions and conflicts around the world
that you have created let us pause to
understand that you not only are a god
of love but that you are a God of
Peace we see and hear the tensions and
conflicts surrounding the many issues
within our country and within the
granite
state let us
pause let us listen before we
speak let us try to understand each
other's point of view even when it may
differ from our
own oh God I pray for each member of
this house and ask that you guide them
as they strive to make effective and
meaningful decisions for all people of
this great state of New Hampshire they
don't have an easy job but with your
guidance Lord it becomes a little easier
because you walk with each of them God
keep your guiding hand on each
member Lord I also ask that you be with
all the
leaders as they try to lead to the best
of their ability they too do not have an
easy job but when we all work together
in harmony when we pause until you are
done
mixing we accomplish things that bring
glory and honor to your name be with us
through this day and Lord make this a
fruitful day
amen the chair recognizes a member from
summersworth representative Kevin
Vincent who will lead us in a pledge of
allegiance to the FL flag of the United
States of America to the for it stands
one nation God indivisible liy and
justice for
all J recognizes a member from Hook at
representative Michael yakubovich who
will now perform our national
[Music]
anthem
for
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Buras Canon Cleaver
kushman Elliot Ellis falam gay gorg Mary
Griffin Healey Hopper Bill King leus
Littlefield Macky major marsten Newton
oxel
ruard salow Janice Schmidt Shen the day
important business Representatives B
DeSaro Amanda Balden Crawford cross Fox
Homa kofalt laflame lton maville McBeth
McKinny mner nordgren Nutter upam oarn
sandborn
Susi Southworth Spain Tudor verville the
day illness in the family
Representatives Kate Murray Rulo and
safas the house these leaves as absence
will be granted unless otherwise ordered
by the house
the house will attend to an introduction
of guests Mr Speaker please welcome Emma
augur student at Winchester School our
page for the
day Mr Speaker please welcome agneska
lanzara wife of Representative lanzara
Mark Ankerberg father of Representative
Ankerberg Eddie and Robin kazinski
guests of Representative lales Ellen
colb guest of Representative nder
Janette vle grandmother of
Representative lebranch ronstein and
Rowan Bratz guests of Representative Bob
Green Peter love it guest of
Representative Weston Carrie spire and
Danny Mills guests of Representative
Duty Karen gripo Guest of Representative
post uh Evan oxenham husband of
Representative oxenham the former member
from Amherst The Honorable Reed panace
and Heather Burch guest of
Representative Howard Pearl The
Honorable Nancy Murphy former member
from marac guest of Representative rung
they are with us in the gallery
[Applause]
today and Mr Speaker please welcome our
special guests verdie Packard and
Barbara Jura sister and cousin of the
speaker they are with us in the gallery
[Music]
[Applause]
today Welcome to the New Hampshire
house the house will attend to a
resolution Mr Speaker representative
Osborne and wner offer the following
resolved that the House of
Representatives informed The Honorable
Senate it is ready to meet in joint
convention for the purpose of attending
to an address by the former president of
Poland Le
wena are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the resolution is
adopted
e
J the chair recognizes the clerk for a
message Mr Speaker the Senate is ready
to meet with the honorable House of
Representatives in joint convention for
the purpose of attending to an address
by the former president of Poland Le
wena the sergeant arms will escort Our
Guest as I introduced by the clerk the
chair recognizes the
clerk
Mr Speaker The Honorable
[Applause]
Senate
Mr Speaker the president of the Senate
The Honorable Chuck Morris of
[Applause]
Salem
The
Joint The Joint convention will come to
order to welcome our special guest Le
palena the former president of
[Applause]
Poland
do
Our Guest today has lived a life of
service dedicated to serving Poland's
history and leading the solidarity
movement Paving the way to freedom for
its
people through his active engagement he
successfully led the first independent
and oppositional social movement in the
Soviet
block his vision of working together in
an effort to oppose the Communist Regime
gained so much popularity that martial
law was introduced and talks of Freedom
were immediately met with force and
arrest for his determination and his
courage to stand up for the rights of
his fellow countrymen he was awarded the
Nobel Peace Prize in
threats did not deter him he it gave him
the motivation to keep going he knew
there was too much at stake and in
1989 he was the leader of the opposition
delegation during Roundtable talks and
eventually with determination he led the
compromise with the Communist
authorities in the election of
1989 the formation of the first
non-communist cabinet in the Soviet
block came to
be in 1990 our esteemed guest was
elected president of free
Poland
[Applause]
he remained engaged with the people
supported Poland's accession to Nato and
the European Union and with his ideals
changed Poland and became the country's
strongest Advocate on the world
stage today he continued his life's
Mission by traveling the world and
speaking to audiences about the peaceful
trans position he fostered toward peace
and democracy and through his lectures
he inspires both young and old to find
Common Ground based on universal values
and
solidarity his work is widely known and
his accolades include Poland's highest
order the order of the White Eagle as
well as the order of the palana
restituta the medal of
freedom numerous honorary degrees and
honorary citizens ship in 35 cities
around the
world his legacy will continue on in
history and has reached Millions through
his lectures and his foundation the Le
wenza Institute this is an Institute
that brings together people of all
social groups and nurtures them to
discuss the ever evolving political
landscape encouraging Independence and
freedom it is my pleasure and privilege
to welcome Le valenza to the general
court of New
Hampshire welcome Mr welcome Mr
[Applause]
President sh
ladies and
gentlemen you need an electrician here
don't you uh
so honorable uh members of the House Of
The senates Honorable speakers uh after
that Applause I know that the second
task which we need to really Implement
and fulfill right now will be
accomplished with your
support uh the previous struggle we all
thought with your support and your
contribution uh brought uh the collapse
of the Soviet
Union the collapse of the war so
act of the ComicCon if you remember what
it was we reunited
Germany and back then at that point I
wanted to accomplish even
more I was actually wishing to eliminate
the cause of problem
that um created difficulties uh over the
centuries in the world and
Europe which means I wanted to
disintegrate former Soviet Union even
further but American politicians did not
allow me to go any
further and maybe back then they were
right they were
correct
however looking at the current situation
U right now as a revolutionary I think
that right now is the propitious moment
for us to finish that task which I
failed to
[Applause]
[Music]
accomplish yes the
there is one condition for it to be
successful the United States really has
to succumb to the role of the leader in
the
world the United States has to organize
the world to carry out that struggle for
the final
success
and as I said before in my judgment this
is the opportune moment for us to win
the final
Victory and I think my generation uh was
given by Providence two major goals to
accomplish uh I judge that we accomp the
first part that is eliminating
unnecessary boundaries and
barriers eliminate the Soviet Union the
warso P that's what we
[Applause]
accomplished but all this was carried
out
in order to have a new safe and secure
and peaceful
world however this world cannot be such
as yet because we have two still two
remnants lingering on from the old era
that is Russia and
China however the technology and the
technological advancement that we as
mankind have accomplished uh demands
from us larger structures in which we
organize ourselves larger modules so to
speak maybe you don't observe it as
clearly from your perspective of New
Hampshire and the United States but if
you look at Europe and um you have have
to realize that there were so many
separate countries within
it when our forefathers invented a bike
when they could could move faster around
they created out of the
villages countries states
milons
whereas now our technological
advancement really forces us to realize
that a single state a single country is
not big enough we need to create larger
structures but in order to integrate us
into those bigger structures throughout
the world we need a world
leader
back um during the times of our struggle
things seems clearcut there was an evil
empire and there was a good
Empire when the evil empire is no longer
there the United States is faced with a
need to redefine its role and its
tasks and I believe uh in my view this
new era still requires us to find
answers to three most important
questions and I believe it's under the
American leadership that we can do
it what should serve as the foundations
for us integrated in the integrating in
this new
era and right now the whole world is
trying to find the answer to
it so when I raise the issue of the
foundations uh I hear in response two
different answers for
uh half of the world claimed that it's
enough to base ourselves on freedoms and
Liberties a free market economy and
legislation they say that it would be a
good ground and Bone backbone to the
Future whereas the remaining half claim
that this will not lead us
anywhere
they claim that instead we should reach
a consensus on the values that we can
all share and on which we can establish
things and I refer to those shared
values as a kind of a uh secular Ten
Commandments and only then can we
introduce a free market economy and
appropriate
legislation and for the moment we cannot
really overcome this debate and uh
decide which way to
go however if we do find the answer to
this first question the second one will
appear uh what should be the economic
system applicable and actually
appropriate for the new era and the New
Order in the world commun certainly
communism as such is out of
question and I'm not claiming now that
it was either bad or good as a eonic
system but simply it has proven totally
ineffective throughout the
world mankind has no time for further
experiments so communism is
out but certainly if someone would like
to say that maybe capitalism is the
response I think the capitalism which we
observe in today's world is not perfect
either it proved effective when we were
confined to our respective countries
states antagonistic blocks then it was
effective and I've heard a reference to
that time of as a rats race one country
one State trying to out chase the
other and that capitalist system allowed
for people who could not keep the pace
with the others to become
jobless so bearing this in mind I think
that if we want to have um the answer to
my second question out of the capitalist
system we need to retain the premarket
economy whereas all its other elements
have to be
redefined we need to find the jobless
people all of them give them give them
work and make them work hard
now and the third third question that um
arises
is how to handle populism and
demagoguery and politicians who cheat in
their
majority bearing in mind another fact
that until the end of the 20th century
forly or more formally or less formally
all societies believed in a
God and many societies have rejected God
as such
now until the end of the 20th century we
were scared of Communism and of the
Soviet
Union this is no longer in place these
are no longer in
place
hence the op question what can serve as
a self-control for Society members when
they fear no God and they fear nothing
else but to to Briefly summarize it the
interest in terms of respective
countries states is no longer
valid we need to readjust our
perspective to larger
structures uh readjust our thinking to
the perspective of this new era of
information intellect and
globalization as a generation we are
found in between the two
eras one has collapsed and the other one
has not uh taken its final shape yet
just
and if we look at all the world's
organizations all the uh systems all the
political uh parties for example they
are totally unfit to serve the new era
you can see it even better on the
example of
Europe where you can very clearly see
that left-wing parties are much more
rtist than the rightist parties and vice
versa and uh it is ridiculous to look at
a at Christian
parties you will hardly find a single
believer being a member of a Christian
so to say
party so we cannot allow for such a
situation to
continue
and I believe there is only one aspect
in our life worldwide that has been
proving
effective uh that is traffic
regulations whereas everything else
throughout the world resembles a
situation where we want to drive but
there are no traffic
regulations so here I am begging you on
my
needs we need to restore the leadership
position of the United States in the
world the Providence has given you such
a strong potential and you can really be
the leader to the
world but by any by any chance you are
very very unwar willing to continue
being their leader share your potential
with Poland and we will try to put it to
a good
[Applause]
use
so if we are successful in this second
part of our task uh they will say of us
in the uh in the future that not only
did they demolish the old order in the
world but they also constructed a good
one the demolishing of the old order was
led by Poland obviously Poland was
greatly assisted by the United States
and many other
people and we played that role very
effectively simply because we had been
prayed through our history in struggles
and in
fighting quite simply because of our
geographical
location uh we were we are located
between two powerful peoples the
Russians and the
German who enjoy military socializing as
you may
remember so they would visit and revisit
one
another years back when there were no
airplanes and they would resort to hor
driven carriages they would always need
to take the shortest way across
Poland you were free to um construct
your wonderful country your wonderful
United States of America doing
businesses meanwhile we had to stay
alert all the time occasionally even
forced to flee our home
there was in a way an advantage to that
location because people living there and
experiencing this uh learned how to
anticipate future developments and um
have an quick Judgment of of the
situation maybe some senior citizens can
still remember that before the outbreak
of the second world war polls were
trying to warn the world that the war
was
imminent and what did we hear in
response the world said who cares we're
not going to die for
dancing we were trying to warn the world
at the end of the second world war
claiming that Stalin was going to cheat
on the world that he was going to
install the Communist Regime throughout
half of the
world and that's exactly and
unfortunately was true because we ended
up in the zone of influence of the
Soviets meanwhile now I think we have
this opportunity to put the final end to
the old order in the
world uh I guess you you know some
Polish people maybe you've met
them you may know that the Polish people
are very proud very um they love freedom
and they are very
Democratic when two Polish people meet
they will establish at least three
political parties between the
two and with the Communist Regime we
were forced to comply with one political
party
only so this is my plea under your
leadership American leadership we can
really improve this
world for the time being obviously we
need to focus on the day-to-day
assistance to
Ukraine people in Ukraine are murdered
killed starved and chased away from
homes Poland has embraced over three
million uh Ukrainian refugees mostly
women with
children
and that is
obviously
[Applause]
that is obviously what we have to
continue doing and it's an obvious thing
for us to do and for the world to be
helping
us but then the the second track of our
activities should be all the efforts to
give the final blow to the current state
of Russia of the Russian
[Music]
regime because even if we defeat Russia
militarily today uh in 5 to 10 years
from now a new Putin will
rise uh quite naturally because Russia
in its today's format is far too large
too large a country and on top of it
with a bad regime that's
terrible so that's second uh strategy uh
is that under the leadership of the
United States and the guidance of the
United Nations we need to force a new
political system at to be introduced
into
Russia we must not allow for a single
individual a Madman uh threatening the
rest of the
world and it's the system that they have
introduced in Russia allows him for
that and in case this strategy fails I
have an alternative
one
Russia is currently composed of about 60
different peoples like the
ukrainians uh former republics that over
the centuries have been absorbed into
Russia Soviet Union on the way and have
been russified
so I believe this alternative strategy
May consist in Awakening those people
motivating them to oppose Russia and to
want and to make them want Break Free
away from
Russia and what I think uh we want to do
is not against Russia or the Russian
people on the contrary Russia and the
Russian people will be grateful to us
because they too have been giving lives
unnecessarily for the centuries because
of their bad
regimes instead Russia can be such a
beautiful
country but not bigger than having 50
million
inhabitants so I think we are now
standing the chance of giving this final
blow and let us get down to work in
order order to uh pull the right
triggers very much thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
Senator bosor and Bradley and senator
Bradley moveed that the joint convention
arise are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those oppose nay
the eyes have it the joint convention is
adjourned
kind
e
for
the house will be in
[Music]
order as many of you
know one of
our long-term
colleagues is
um
not doing too well
unfortunately so I'm going to take a
minute
here and uh talk about our dear
colleague Mary Griffin a little
bit pres Mary Griffin holds a
distinction of being the eldest member
of the New Hampshire House of
Representatives which is a f fitting
tribute to her as she celebrates her
birthday she's currently serving in her
13th term it's been serving a
constituents in the state of New
Hampshire for 26
years she is an esteemed member of the
Ways and Means
Committee she served as legal secretary
and Court Clerk for the town of Windham
she was also miss senior New Hampshire
in
1993 and a top 10 finalist for miss
senior America in
1993 she was active in the Windam Senior
Center and hosted her own cable TV talk
show Windham watch served as supervisor
of the checklist in
Windham former vocalist in gold metal
tap dancer and she has graced this
chamber with her rendition of the
national anthem on many
occasions she and her late husband Andy
Griffin were instrumental in
construction of Griffin Park firly known
as Tera Farm is now a lasting Legacy in
a place that windh him families and
residents can
enjoy the lasting impacts of her
friendship leadership and unwavy
dedication to the community of Windham
the state of New Hampshire I felt by all
congratulations on the distinction for
your exemplary Public
Service I hope everybody keeps Mary
Griffin in their
prayers
the house will attend to Senate
messages for what reason does the member
eyes Mr Speaker I move that the remarks
about our dear friend and colleague be
placed in the permanent journal with all
of our good wishes without
objection house will attend to Senate
messages
Mr Speaker Representatives excuse me the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 254
relative to the placement of minors in
Secure
settings representes rice and that non
representa rice is
recognized represent rice and umberger
move that we non-c Concur and the chair
recognizes repres representative rice to
speak thank you Mr Speaker so the powers
that be made this bill 10 times worse
even worse than what we already have in
statute so I'm asking you to please vote
to non-c concur thank
you the are you ready for the question
the motion is to non-c concur on House
Bill
254 all those in favor say I I those
oppos
nay the eyes have it and the motion to
non-c concur is
adopted house will attender further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
curs of the house in the passage of the
following title bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate has the concurrence of the house
house bill
293 relative to the procedure for
adoption of a minor
child
Zen R moves that we Concur and is
recognized thank you Mr Speaker so um
all they really did
was remove the um I'm sorry hold
on they made it so that the person is
related and you don't have to have an
assessment as long as um the child has
lived with you for two consecutive years
as opposed to three so I ask that you
concur the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 293 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay uh division has been requested
members will take your
seats only those in the
chamber if you weren't in the chamber on
The Voice
vote if you weren't in the chamber on
The Voice vote you can't come
in St turned on speaker and turn your
voting stations on
please
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill
293 if you're in favor you will press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
speaker all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the
vote 144 voting aay 128 voting nay
committee report is
adopted
yes the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the Fall following entitled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1103 relative to certain Assets in a
divorce
proceeding representative rice moves
that the house concurrent is recognized
to
speak thank you Mr Speaker uh they
simply added a provision that either
party may ask for a modification of a
property settlement in regards to an
animal so I so people don't fight over
their dogs the court can help settle it
so I ask that you
concur the question is whether to concur
with the senator are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay no the eyes have it and
the motion's
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs of the house in the passage of
the following en titled bill with
Amendment In this passage of which
amendment of the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 1280
prohibiting a parents refusal to
vaccinate a child from being used as
evidence in any proceeding to
terminating parental rights and enacting
the 2009 interstate compact for the
placement of
children representative rice moves at
the house Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker so what they
did was they strengthened the language
to shall
not be used so a vaccination shall not
be used if you choose not to vaccinate
for a reason for taking your children
away they also attached the ICPC the
interstate compact for the placement of
children which I cannot express how
important it is that we have a seat at
the table for this one so that we can
protect kids that we are sending across
state lines and that we know that
they're in a safe environment and the
same for kids coming to us so I ask that
you
concur the question is on the motion of
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos
a the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attenda further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs of the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate as the concurrence of the
house house bill
1531 repealing certain statutory
commissions relating to children and
relative to membership of the oversight
Commission on children
services representes rice and umberger
move that we concur representative
Rice's recognized
speak thank you Mr Speaker speaker so
they did exactly what we knew they were
going to do on the repeal of the grand
families commission and child abuse
fatalities during that repeal they they
pulled people from each one of those
committees so they can be placed on the
oversight Commission on children's
services so we're all in one area
instead of trying to attend three
different meetings a month to go over
the same thing so I ask that you
concur the question is on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I
all those oppose nay the eyes have it
and the motion is
adopted for what purpose does a member
rise and Mr Mr Speaker help me figure
out the right way to say this I would
like to move that the remarks of both
the speaker's introduction of President
Valena uh be in the permanent Journal as
well as I don't think we need to include
polish but maybe the transl leaders
that's the part I don't know what to say
um the remarks of President Valena given
the historic nature of his visit um
included in our permanent Journal thank
you so it's to move that former
president Wes's remarks be printed in
the journal without
objection so
order
the house will attend to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate conures
of the house on the passage of the
following titled bill with Amendment the
passage which amendment the Senate as to
concurrence of the house house bill
1039 relative to the definition of
Beverage manufacturer retail outlet
certain liquor licenses and fees
including beer and Specialty beverage
Festival licenses relative to direct to
Consumer shipments of alcohol
representative hunt moves at the house
concurrent is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr speaker
this bill was uh the Commerce
committee's uh cleanup bill for
different statutes we passed in the past
years um the we started out with one
bill we had two amendments the Senate
added two amendments one of them is
adding specially beverages to festivals
I think if we have a Polish Festival we
would like to have some Polish beer and
second is uh the uh delivery of beer by
manufacturers tell me who is opposed to
the idea that beer can be delivered to
their home
the question is on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted V will attend to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
of the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate as concurrence of the house house
bill
1469 establishing a committee to study
the need for anti-discrimination
legislation in the New Hampshire
Financial Services industry
representative hunt moves at the house
Concur and is recognized to
speak forgot about this bill um yes so
this bill uh is the Senate has said that
this is a very complicated issue and we
really should study it and the Commerce
Committee agrees so please support it
the question is on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oppose nay no
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
347 relative to driving with a suspended
license representative abis moves at the
house Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the only
change the only amendment it does is
change the effective dat so please I ask
everyone to concur thank you the
question is on the motion to concur are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I all those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
the house will attend to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 1178 prohibiting the
state from enforcing any federal statute
regulation or presidential exec itive
order that restricts or regulates the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms representative abbis moves at the
house concurrent is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker this bill
previously passed the the house with
bipar and support and just some
clarification on how this policy would
be administered this is not a
nullification law it it does not
override or supersede Federal La in any
manner what this will do we'll simply
create a policy with the state of New
Hampshire will not enforce Federal
firearm laws and and rules and
regulations that are inconsistent with
our state
law the
concept of not the state not enforcing
federal laws is not new we've had this
debate on other subjects we discussed it
when we were discussing immigration even
cannabis we've had this conversation
before it's a matter of what the
policy uh we're going to put forward is
this does not prevent law enforcement
from enforcing other state laws are
working with Federal uh federal law
enforcement agents when it comes to
enforcing other state laws unrelated to
Firearms
altogether the people of New Hampshire
have supported the Second Amendment
consistent since the founding of
consistently since the founding of the
state and that was even more evident
when the state and the people supported
adopting uh Article 28 to the New
Hampshire
Constitution we've heard candidates
running for higher office candidates for
the president of United States saying if
they were elected fortunately that
candidate was not elected saying that
they would come and take your firearms
from you and require a
surrender it was on TV I heard it it
[Applause]
happened the house will come to
order
as I was saying that that candidate
still did not win uh any primary state
so but my my point is is
that if the federal government wishes to
create laws and rules and regulations
that are inconsistent with what the
populace of the state has has
traditionally supported the B the burden
should fall on the federal government to
enforce those laws not the state so I
ask that we concur because the only
change that was made was simply to
provided that the state would still be
permitted to report domestic violence
restraining orders into the Knicks that
is the currently under New Hampshire law
that is the law and the practice it was
simply for
clarification purposes only to make sure
that that information was properly or
would continue to be reported to the
Knicks it's not new
information it is the same information
that's been provided already that's also
a public record might I add that once
there is a restraining order domestic
violence restraining order anyone could
have access to it so I ask the body to
please concur thank you does a member
yield for a
question no the member does not
yield representative Bert requests a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded okay then this will be a roll
call vote please take your
seats
the question is whether to concur this
is a roll call vote representative
Harriet gothra is recognized for for a
parliamentary inquiry and the house will
come to
order thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the other body
essentially handcuffs the state and
local law enforcement officials when it
comes to enforcing administering or
cooperating with federal gun laws and
regulations in New
Hampshire and if I
know that it very well jeopardizes any
federal funding tied to the enforcement
of these laws and
regulations furthermore if I know that
the bottom line is that the changes
coming over from the other body failed
to fix flaws in the bill that created
gapping holes when it comes to Public
Safety also we also be giving more
freedom to gun traffickers felons and
our state to endanger both the public
and Law Enforcement
Officers I ask you is that what you want
I also ask you in the strongest possible
terms to vote red to non-c concur on
this
bill representative Bert is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know House Bill 1178 is an
act prohibiting the state from enforcing
any federal
statute regulation or presidential
executive order that restricts and
regulates the right of the people to
keep and bear
arms Mr Speaker if I also
know that this bill will in no way
stop our local County or
state law enforcement from assisting in
any
matters other than regulating
guns to um to the
feds Mr Speaker if I also know that
under current
law that the courts can and do report to
Nicks a domestic
violence so the Senate amended
this in it is current
law lastly Mr
Speaker the majority of New Hampshire
citizens want
1178 to protect their rights to keep and
bear arms would I now press the green
button to concur with the Senate thank
you Mr
Speaker the question is on the motion to
concur this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 163 in the affirmative 143 in the
negative the motion is
adopted
the house will attend to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
of the house in the passage of the
following titled bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill
1335 relative to the parole board and
the procedure for medical parole for
prisoners representative abis moves at
the house Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker all the
amendment did was change to the
reference a term of resident to prisoner
in order so the language would would be
consistent with the rest of the rsas so
please concur thank you the question is
on the motion to concur are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppose nay the eyes have
it and the and the motion is adopted the
house will attend to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate URS of
the house in the passage of the
following title bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill
1388 relative to the unol unsolicited
disclosure of an intimate image
representative abis moves at the house
Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr
Speaker I ask everyone to concur all the
amendment did was clarify the consent
language although I helped draft the
original consent language I can live
with the amendment and it does not
change the fundamental purpose of the
bill so please concur thank you the
question is on the motion to concur are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose Nay n the
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
the house will attend a further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
of the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 1682 establishing the
law enforcement conduct Review Committee
and the New Hampshire police standards
and training Council and making an
appropriation therefore Representatives
abis and umberger move that the house
concur represent of abis is recognized
to
speak thank you Mr Speaker all the
amendment did was correct one
grammatical error and in addition to
that provided a definition for
administrative suspension please concur
thank you the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of the
house in the passage of the following
titled bill with Amendment and the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill
1125 relative to school emergency
plans representative lad moves at the
house Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker uh this bill
as amended by the uh Senate uh changes
basically some terminology on the
Emergency Management PL submitted to
Homeland Security by the school
districts changes the emergency response
plan now calls at the Emergency
Operations plan in conjunction with
municipalities uh changes a date in
which the plans have to be submitted
from September 1 to October 15th minor
changes and if uh you don't submit your
plan for two consecutive years this
reported doe and doe will get after you
I ask that you concur with this uh
Amendment and Bill the question is on
the motion to concur are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose nay the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted the house will
attend to further Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs of the house
in the passage of the following entitled
bill with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1131 relative to
facial covering policies for
schools representative lad moves at the
house concur is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker uh 1131 deals with
the maske wearing in schools uh it
basically supports the policy and Bill
as proposed by this body where it
prohibits policies to uh be uh adopted
in a or implemented or in fact uh
enforced in a school district that
mandate the wearing of uh facial masks
with the exception of uh those
situations in a classroom where you're
dealing with with chemistry or safety
issues in a Vocational Center uh it also
changes the date of this uh passage when
it goes in effect we had 60 days after
passage uh the Senate amended to be
immediately upon P passage thank
you the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos
n the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attend a further
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
to the house in the passage of the
following en titled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as it concurrence of the house
house bill 11:32 relative to
applications for Charter conversion
School representative lad moves at the
house Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you very much the as amended
by the Senate they did not change any of
our wording they added a phrase that the
base of is that nothing in this section
of law shall be construed to limit a
school district's obligation to provide
special Education Services to all
qualifying students that might be in a
charter conversion school we ask that
you
concur the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay no the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house will attend
to further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate URS of the house and the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked to concur to
the house house bill 1311 prohibiting
persons charged with or convicted of
certain assault or controll drug
possession violations from employment in
a public school or being granted
teaching credentials representative lad
moves at the house Concur and is
recognized to speak thank you very much
Mr Speaker the Senate modified this bill
by stating that uh the Senate version
inserts felony level within the last 10
years so if there's something occurs
within a 10year span uh then the
certificate's not awarded we ask that
you concur
the questions on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
the house in the passage of the
following titled bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
ask occurrence of the house house bill
1381 relative to student school board
members representative lad moves at the
house Concur and is recognized to speak
this bill required one uh each School
Board to have one member non- voting
member from every high school that might
be in that District they change the date
of Effectiveness here from UH 60 days
afterwards to passage uh from January 1
2023 2 60 days after passage I ask that
you concur the questions on the motion
to concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I all those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs of the house in the passage of
the following titled bill with the
amendment in which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill
1398 establishing a committee to study
the feasibility of centralized criminal
history records check in education
representative lad moves at the house
Concur and is recognized to
speak we ask that you concur this simply
Chang the effective date of the
bill the questions on the motion to
concur ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs of the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate as it concurs to the house
house bill
1513 relative to the definition of a
child with a disability under special
education laws and providing funding for
special education costs for students
over age 21 until their 22nd birthday
representative lad moves at the house
Concur and is recognized to
speak this bill uh thank you Mr Speaker
this bill uh is has been amended in in
uh conjunction with the first US circuit
Court's decision in Rhode Island where
we look at the age of a student that's
qualified for special education services
uh as it's in the amendment of the
Senate special education services be
provided uh upon the age of child
reaching 21 21 and until they reach age
22 uh it also provides funding for the
time that the uh student is within
school after they hit age 21 through the
time that they do change uh and become
22 years or they hit their 22nd birth
date regardless if it's in the school
year or not and provides provider
provider costs provider costs oftentimes
range from about 22,000 to $140,000 for
some of these students and the effective
change was uh uh date for this was
changed uh from July 1 uh 2023 to
effective upon passage to be in
conjunction with court case that came
out of rad
Island the question is on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos n the eyes have it and the motion
is adopted the house will attend to
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs of the House of the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask concur to the
house house bill
1594 relative to assistance to certain
students with disabilities in
registering to
vote representative lad moves at the
house concurrent is recognized to speak
thank you as amended by the Senate it
reads if appropriate upon a student
reaching age 17 the IEP team When
developing accommodations for an
individual's disabilities or addressing
a 504 plan that appropriate community
living and citizenship training goal or
competency to attain that goal be
included in the IP or the 504 we ask
that you concur the questions on the
motion to concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
conures of the house in the passage of
the following titled bill with Amendment
in the passage which amendment the
Senate asked concurrence of the house
house bill
1624 relative to students with
disabilities participating in
co-curricular activities and making an
appropriation therefore representative
lad moves at the house Concur and is
recognized to speak this Bill had wide
support within this body when we talk
about Unified sports and students with
IEPs or disabilities participating in
activities um what it does it uh changes
the funding language from the each uh
first year of a ium where there' be
$50,000 and they're just simply changing
it for each bium $50,000 would be
provided and no more than $4,000 per
program I ask that you concur the
questions on the motion to concur are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
the house will attend the further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concurrence of house house
bill 1626 relative to the unique pupil
identification
system representative lad moves at the
house concurrent is recognized to speak
thank you very much Mr Speaker uh this
bill right here is some cleanup uh from
the Department of Education and uh
supported very much by the committee it
deals with uh students that are enrolled
in adult education charter schools and
scholarship programs where that their
information which is provided to doe uh
be included and the unique pupil
identifier be used for these students so
their personal information is not known
by others and we will also use the
random num random number generator as we
do for all students it just takes all
these students from these other
components of education and lumps them
under this so that their uh personal
information is protected by law I ask
that you concur the questions on the
motion to concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house will attend
to further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate URS of the house in the
passage of the following en titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask the concurrence
of the house house bill 1671 relative to
the content of an adequate education
representative lad moves at the house
concurrent is recognized to speak thank
you very much Mr Speaker uh the senate
in their wisdom believes that we should
have computer science and digital
literacy as part of the content of of an
adequate education uh we've had it there
before but uh we had initially put it as
an applied portion in all subject areas
we concur computer science and digital
literacy is important and we ask that
you
concur the question is on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house will attend
to further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate curs of the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with am the passage of which amendment
the Senate as the concurrence of the
house house bill 144 relative to the
absentee ballot request
forms representative Barbara Griffin
moves at the house non-c Concur and is
recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker this house
bill dealt with changes in the absentee
ballot application form the changes we
made here in the house were adopted in
the Senate however the Senate expanded
uh changes to the absentee ballot and
expanded the definitions of what would
qualify you to have a disability uh
disability is in our
Constitution and they sought to expand
it essentially to categories that we
used for under the state of
emergency uh the committee urges you to
to nonc concur with the Senate changes
in regards to this and this will put uh
absentee ballot status back to where it
was two years ago thank you
the question is on the motion of non-c
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house shall attend to
further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 514 relative to ballot
column rotation
representative Barbara Mo Griffin moves
at the house Concur and is recognized to
speak this bill that we passed out with
a modification to the formula to
determine how the columns on ballots are
rotated we have been using for a few
years now a fairly complicated formula
with the Secretary of State's office
sought to make less complicated uh the
Senate agreed a change was made and
actually made a change going back to the
previous method ology that was used
which was basing the rotation on random
the random numbering of the Senate
districts that method has been
previously deemed to be legal and I ask
for your concurrence to adopt that
methodology the question is on the
motion to concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house and the the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1174 relative to election
Challengers representative Barbara
Griffin moves at the house concurrent is
recognized to speak thank you Mr Speaker
this bill is an attempt to provide
clearer direction to moderators as to
where Challengers can be at the polling
place issues had been raised with
actually being able to see what was
going on or hear what was being said um
And in regards to the observation of
counting both by hand and keeping an an
line of sight to the ballot tabulators
uh the house made modifications that
provided a distance regulation the
Senate took out that distance regulation
but put in a further clarification to
specifically say the challengers must be
able to see and hear and kept the
language in regards to seeing the
tabulator I ask for your concurrence
thank you the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house will attend
to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill
1203 relative to voter registration and
verification of voter
identity representative Barbara Griffin
moves at the house non-concurrent is
recognized to speak thank you Mr speaker
this was a very long Bill about 18 pages
with changes to many statutes in an
effort to clean them up as to a ruling
of the court that occurred in regards to
proof of domicile or what some of you
who have been here previously might know
as Senate Bill 3 the problem was when
the House reviewed the changes it it
revealed that the bill actually did a
lot more than what it was represented to
be the house spent a fair amount of time
going through those change es um and try
to make a process clearer taking out the
language that the court had ruled was
unconstitutional the Senate essentially
redid our changes to this bill with an
another 18-page bill that came back um
after a review of the language it was
determined that it was the changes were
simply uh in two gross in amount for us
to be able to reconcile and the
Secretary of State's office has uh conf
affirm that they can continue to
administer the elections and interpret
the statute without this bill I ask that
you nonc concur with the Senate thank
you the question is on the motion to
non-c concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the house will
attend to further Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs of the house
in the passage of the following entitled
bill with amendment in the passage of
which amendment the Senate asks the
concurrence of the house house Bill
1467 relative to recounts of state
representative races during a general
election representative Barbara Griffin
moves at the house Concur and is
recognized to speak thank you Mr Speaker
this bill as we have previously passed
uh dealt with a a new requirement that
when a recount is requested and that is
of course we all know usually for a
House of Representative seat um that
there automatically be also a recount of
a topof the ticket race a presidential
Governor depending on what the race is
uh the other body provided in their
change for a maximum number of recounts
to be done with this additional audit
provision and also required that all of
the top at the ticket races be done I
ask for your
concurrence the question is on the
motion to concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house will attend
a further Senate m messages Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs with the house and
the passage of the following entitled
bill with amendment in the passage of
which amendment the Senate ask the
concurrence of the house house bill
1496 requiring political subdivisions to
make voter checklists available in
electronic form to any Resident
Representatives Barbara Griffin and
umberger move that the house concur
representative Barbara Griffin's
recognized to speak thank you Mr Speaker
the bill as passed by this body provided
that a checklist which people are
entitled to now under law their public
records uh be provided in an electronic
format the Senate change uh was simply
clarifying that the clerk could ask the
requestor what electronic format they
would like it in I ask your concurrence
the questions on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asks the
concurrence of the house house bill
1134 establishing a commission to study
proper labeling and disposal of
disposable
wipes representative Pearl moves at the
house concurrent is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
Amendment adds one more duty to the
labeling and proper disposal of the
Disposable WIP study committee the
addition Duty will be to look at
engineering and technological
developments that may mitigate the
problem of non-f flushable waste the ENA
committee asks you to support the motion
to concur the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos n the eyes have it and the motion
is adopted the house will attend to
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 1168
establishes a committee to study the New
Hampshire law relative to soil
conditioners and relative to costs
eligible for reimbursement from the oil
discharge and Disposal cleanup fund
representative Pearl moves at the house
Concur and is recognized to speak thank
you Mr Speaker the uh Senate added a
non-gain Amendment to the bill relating
to the oil discharge and cleanup fund
the amended version will allow for uh
the increase of the reimbursement costs
distributed from the fund for abandoned
underground storage tanks from
$2,250 to
$3,300 the increase is necessary to keep
Pace with the higher cost of removal the
ENA committee ask you to support the
motion to concur the questions on the
motion to concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I all
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the house shall
attend to further Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house
House Bill 11 186 relative to companion
animals during a declared state of
emergency representative Pearl moves at
the house concurrent is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
made a minor language change to the bill
to more clearly clarify the
responsibility of an emergency shelter
accommodating a companion animal during
an emergency evacuation please support
the concur the questions on the motion
to concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house will attend
to further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1420 prohibiting the issuance of new
landfill permits until the state Solid
Waste plan is updated representative
Pearl moves at the house Concur and is
recognized to speak thank you again Mr
Speaker the Senate made a minor
grammatical change to this bill to fix a
technical error that did not change the
intent of the bill so please support the
concur the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house will attend
to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
of the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill
1454 relative to permits for the
sighting of new
landfills representative of pearl moves
at the house Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
Amendment grants the New Hampshire Dees
the ability to adopt rules under 541a
that will allow for the use of uh
project Improvement allowances in
reducing the 5year distance to travel
setb from surface water bodies this
amendment caps the maximum allowance of
reductions to three credit years that
may be achieved by implementing
technological monitoring or funding
guarantee methods the ENA committee
asked you to support the conance the
questions on the motion to concur are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill
1584 establishing a capital Improvement
grant program for the benefit of state
fairs and AG cultural
Affairs representative Pearl moves at
the house concurrent is recognized to
speak thank you again Mr Speaker for the
last time uh the Senate amended the bill
to make the
$250,000 appropriation a one-time
dispersement rather than an annual
dispersement they also removed the
million doll cap on the fund
additionally they added a requirement
for the grant recipient to provide 30%
or greater in matching funds or in kind
Services as a condition of elib
Eligibility I'll get it uh the ENA
committee ask you to support this
concurr motion thank you representative
Pearl moves at the house concur uh sorry
we already did that the question is on
the motion to concur you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those opposed nay no the eyes have it on
the motion is
adopted the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following titled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 84 declaring May 21st
2022 is Ona judge stain's
day representative Maguire moves at the
house concurrent as recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
Amendment merely tweaks the wording of
the Declaration and I recommend you
concur thank you the questions on the
motion to concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the house will
attend to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate URS of
the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill of amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill
591 relative to certain liquor license
fees Representatives Maguire and
umberger move that the house concur
representative Maguire is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
Amendment merely fixes a typo from
licenses to licenses and I hope you will
concur the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house will attend
to further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs to the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 1135
requiring a performance audit of the
department of education education
Freedom account program representative
Maguire moves at the house concurrent is
recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
Amendment merely moves out the effective
excuse me the effective date so that the
audit will have the enrollment data for
next year as well as this coming year in
order to do a more effective and
efficient audit the house agrees and I
hope you will uh the committee agrees
and I hope you will also the questions
on the motion to Cur are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose nay the eyes have it
and the motion is
adopted the house will attend a further
Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
of the house and the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill
1318 relative to penalties for employer
non-compliance with retirement system
requirements representative Maguire
moves at the house Concur and is
recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
Amendment changes the maximum fee from
$25 a day to $200 a day in order to get
the attention of some of the larger
communities that might not pay attention
to $25 a day since the retirement system
has the ability to to assess anything up
to this maximum smaller communities
should not be affected the and so I hope
you will concur the questions on the
motion to concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the house will
attend to further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
to the house in the passage of the
following en titled bill of amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate ask the concurrence of the house
house bill 1535 relative to a one-time
allowance for certain State
retirees Representatives Maguire and
umberg move that the house concur
representative McGuire has recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
amendment of this bill limited the
one-time allowance to only those
retirees making less than $30,000 a year
it's somewhat less generous than the
house version but it does provide
immediate one-time relief to our lowest
paid pensioners who are the ones that
need it they still fund it completely
from
the state general
fund and therefore I hope you will uh
join the join us in supporting this
amend this
change the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the following
Representatives declared conflicts of
interest and did not participate in the
vote Representatives Andress Bergeron
Gordon Harrington McDonald Ma and
Shapiro the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs the house and the passage of the
following titled bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill
1552 establishing a board for the
certification of assessing
persons Representatives Maguire and
umberger moveed that the house concur
representative Maguire is recognized to
speak thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1552 moves used the
board for certification of assessors
from the Dr to the office of
professional LIC Insurance
certification the Senate Amendment
modifies the members of the board which
is agreed to by both the assessing
Standards Board and the Dr and the
oplc and it has much better transition
language to ensure that nobody's license
gets dropped or that rules are
ineffective
while this happens uh it's an
improvement to the bill and I hope you
will support it the questions on the
motion to concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the house will
attend to further Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house and the passage of the following
is title bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence the house house bill
1681 relative to the state building code
and the state fire code
representative Maguire moves at the
house Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
Amendment merely moves the effective
date to effective immediately which the
committee agrees with and the all the
affected parties also support so I hope
you will
also the questions on the motion to
concur you're ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppose
nay no the eyes have it and the motion
is is adopted the house will attend the
further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate refuses
to acceed to the request of the House of
Representatives for committee of
conference on the following Bill House
Bill
1432 prohibiting the use of State funds
for a certain passenger Rail
Project the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house House Bill 381
relative to Laboratory
Testing representative Mark Pearson
moves at the house concurr and is
recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker this bill
authorizes Laboratory Testing without a
licensed medical practitioner's order if
the laboratory offers that test to the
public on a direct access basis any
report of the test results should be
provided directly to the person who is
the subject of the test
this person's medical practitioner is
not obligated to review or act on such a
test all the Senate changed was to
exclude from the provisions of this act
a person under the care of the New
Hampshire County jail or Department of
Corrections Facility I ask you please to
concur the questions on the motion to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos nay no the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the house attend to
further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate has the concurrence of the house
house bill 503 codifying the Council on
housing stability in relative to teleah
health and medically assisted treatment
for substance use
disorder representative Mark Pearson
moves at the house Concur and is
recognized to speak thank you Mr Speaker
this bill does two things first it
reconstitutes the state Council on
housing stability to add certain
additional members so that this Council
will address housing
instability the Senate added to the
council's duties the requirement to
develop a comprehensive state plan on
homelessness the Senate also added to
the house bill an unrelated bill that
would remove certain in-person and
physical location requirements for
Medicaid reimbursements to allow for
medical assisted treatment for substance
use disorder through tele medicine I ask
you to concur please the questions on
the motion to concur are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose
nay all right now I'm in doubt on that
one we'll have a clarification
vote nobody else in just the members in
the
chamber
members take their seats
please
representative
turkot okay the question is on the
motion to concur if you're in favor
press the green button if you're opposed
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 228 in the
affirmative 4 for and the negative the
motion is adopted the loud the few the
Nay the house will attend to further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs of the house and the passage of
the following entitled bill with
amendments in the passage of which
amendments the Senate as the URS to the
house house bill 1022 permitting
pharmacists to dispense the drug Icon by
means of a standing order and
establishing a committee to study the
use of icon to treat
covid-19 representative Mark Pearson
moves that the house concur
representative kerk is recognized to
speak against the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker I Rise to oppose the motion to
concur we should not legislate the
practice of
medicine especially when it contradicts
the best available able medical evidence
permitting a pharmacist to dispense a
medication by a standing order requires
a well- evaluated protocol established
through a broad consensus of providers
and pharmacists using the best available
data but a broad consensus in the use of
icin in covid does not exist you've
heard the claims that over 100 Studies
have shown Ivor mekton to be useful and
helpful in reducing the severity and
duration of
19 but this is not true there have been
numerous studies regarding Ivory mecin
and covid-19 which
sound you suspend for a sec yes sir yeah
I'm right here and I'm having trouble
hearing him can we quiet it down take
conversations outside
please you may
continue yeah um which sound compelling
but on analysis have design flaws they
to small sample sizes there's no
blinding no
randomization uh and various concominant
medications that confound the assessment
even the well-designed studies have
significant limitations so the bottom
line is the there are no definite
conclusions regarding the efficacy of
use of ican in treating covid-19 so we
should confine it to just studies that
are being done the bottom line is that
highquality medication efficacy Studies
have to be randomized double blinded and
Placebo
controlled only a few studies meet that
high criteria and those do not support
the use of icin for the treatment or
prevention of covid-19 outside of
well-designed
studies so when I testified in the other
body against this bill I was asked the
question about well what's the harm in
just going ahead and passing this bill
and doing it and the issue is pretty
straightforward if you allow a standing
order for I and it implies that it is
effective that will divert people from
other truly proven treatments which can
uh treat the disease or even uh
well-proven vaccination which can
decrease the risk of serious disease so
what the Senate did to this bill is they
amended it to have its sunset in July 1
of
2024 the standing order authorization
with Sunset and created a commission to
study the efficacy of I in treating
covid in order to make a
recommendation as to whether the
authorization should be made
permanent now that's totally
backwards it is inappropriate to
legislatively
pretend that there is a consensus and
then evaluate to see if one
exists if it's determined by high
quality studies that iveron has a place
in treating covid-19 you can bet that at
some point it will become come commonly
prescribed without this bill again we
should not legislate the practice of
medicine and we don't legislate
scientific
evidence in summary standing orders with
pharmacists should not be used to
dispense medications for indications
that are not clearly supported by the
best available medical evidence and Ivor
meon does not reach that level of
evidence the Senate's attempt to
compromise
on the lack of evidence is not good and
we should not concur so we can let this
bill die and let high quality research
guide the practice of medicine so please
press red to vote no on the motion to
Concur and I request a division vote
sir representative Mark Pearson has
recognized to speak in support of the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker the Senate added some more
amendments than the ones just mentioned
the standing order shall not be used for
one who is pregnant the standing order
shall not be used for one who is under
18 the person receiving Ivor mechon
through a standing order shall sign an
informed consent statement stating there
is no proven benefit to treating co9
with Ivor mechon the study commission
has already been mentioned the said
provision is 2024 July
1st and I don't know anybody who wants
to use either mechon for
covid who is doing it and they do it
because they don't want to get
vaccinated so it's not drawing people
away from something they're not going to
do anyway and isn't it better to do it
this way than get Ivor mectin from
veterinarian supply
houses therefore I ask you please to
concur the question is on the motion to
concur representative Tony Lakers
requests a roll call is this
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members please take your
seats yes good
point
love
the the questions on the motion to
concur house will come to order
representative Ker's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and if I
know that in the interest of time I did
not review all of the other
modifications made by the Senate as they
do not neutralize the flawed premise and
if I know that the best available
evidence simply does not support the use
of ivory mecin in co9 and if I know that
legislation must be informed by the best
available evidence not poor studies and
wishful thinking and if I know that it
is backwards to approve a treatment and
then look at the evidence and if I know
lastly that we should not legislate the
practice of
medicine what I then press the red
button to vote no on the motion to
concur so another motion could be
brought forward thank
you representative Mark Pearson's
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know there's
far more dangerous stuff available over
the counter
now names the house supp upon requests
later and if I know that this use is not
versus is getting uh
vaccinations but it is instead of
getting Ivor mechon from farm supply
stores would I not vote
Yes by pushing the green
button the questions on the motion to
concur this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
e
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 157 in the affirmative 148 negative
the motion is
adopted
okay I have a lunchtime
announcement if you go downstairs you
will find a lunch today provided by
Walmart for what reason does a member
rise
thank you Mr Speaker to make a motion a
motion I move that the remarks from
previous debate be printed in the
permanent
journal without
objection
okay there is an objection
so and the motion is for the previous
bill
okay the motion is whether to print
remarks uh from the previous debate this
is a division
vote members take your seats
please
the question is whether to print the
remarks from the previous debate this is
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button if you're opposed press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
Andrews representative
Andrews representative Andrew I need a
thumb up or thumb down
please it's locked
it's have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 173 in the affirmative 132 and the
negative the motion passes the house
will stand in recess until
1:10
members take your
seats
[Music]
e
members take your
[Music]
seats
house recogniz the clerk for a senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of
the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 1139 relative to
optimol prescription
requirements representative Pearson
moves that we Concur and is recognized
to speak
thank you Mr Speaker the purpose of this
bill is to require prescriptions for
eyeglasses to contain information of the
interpupillary distance when requested
by the patient or the parent or Guardian
if the patient be a minor this is so
eyeglasses with this essential piece of
information may be ordered online from
discount
sellers the Senate added that nothing
shall prevent the AIC dispenser or their
employer from charging a fee to uh give
this information I ask you please to
concur the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 1139 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is
adopted J recognizes the clerk for
another Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate conures of the house in the
passage of the following titled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask urr of the
house house bill
1320 relative to public exposure of
deceased human
bodies sen Pearson moves we concurrent
is recognize his speak thank you Mr
Speaker this bill repeals the
prohibition against displaying a dead
human body for longer than 24 hours
unless such body is properly embalmed
the Senate's version added that if final
disposition of the body has not occurred
within 48 hours after the funeral home
has obtained physical custody the body
must be embalmed or maintained at a
temperature under 40 fahit or encased
in a closed
container after some discussion and
negotiation among the house sponsor of
the bill our Senator uh who is a
physician and some Funeral Directors the
word came to be to me go ahead and
confer with the Senate so please help me
do that
motion before us is to concur on House
Bill 1320 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted a message J recognizes the clerk
for a senate a motion Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs at the house in the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked a concurrence
of the house house bill
1390 relative to access to language
translation services in tele
medicine president Pearson moves we
Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr
Speaker the house version of this bill
states that if a facility is required to
ensure meaningful language access to
limited English proficient speakers or
to Deer heart of hearing individuals
such access shall be provided regardless
of whether services are provided in
person or by utilizing tele medicine the
Senate version adds pursuant to Federal
statutes and that the medical record be
forwarded to the patients primary care
or traing provider if appropriate but
only subject to the patient's consent I
ask you please to
concur the motion before us is to Cur on
House Bill 1390 are you ready for the
question all those favor say I I those
oppose nay the eyes have it the motion
is adopted J recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs of the house and the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill
1455 relative to state enforcement of
federal vaccination
mandates representative Pearson moves
that we concur in as recognize to
speak thank you Mr Speaker
this bill prohibits state enforcement of
any federal law order or rule that
requires an individual is a condition of
employment or any other activity to
provide proof of vaccination against
covid or to submit more than one test
per month the Senate's Version Moves the
language of the bill from chapter 141 K1
Public Health sovereignty to chapter
275 as a new section one called called
the employee health sovereignty the
Senate's version also adds a section
exempting any health care provider or
contractor subject to a federal vaccine
requirement from the provisions of the
bill both the prime sponsor and the
individual who took point on this in
committee and on the house floor are
amendable to the Senate's changes I ask
you please to
concur motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 14 55 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion
passes J recognizes representative Klein
Knight for a
motion thank you so much Mr Speaker
although this is a really outdated and
sexist thing to do I would request that
the males in the room be allowed to take
off their jackets if they're
hot the chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of
the house in the passage of the
following titled bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate ask the concurrence of the house
house bill
1495 prohibiting the state from
requiring businesses to require vaccine
or documentation related to vaccination
or immunity
status sen Pi's moves we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his motion thank
you Mr Speaker the house version of this
bill prohibits the state from acquiring
businesses to require vaccine or
documentation related to vaccination or
immunity status this however does not
apply to State agencies certifying a
medical facility or to a provider which
is subject to a valid and enforcable
Medicare or Medicaid condition of
participation that imposes a vaccine
requirement the Senate looked at this
they added a
comma and the word a I think we can give
them that I ask you please to
concur the motion before us is to occur
on House Bill 1495 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those opposed n
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs of the house in the
passage of the following titled bill
with Amendment and passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1507 requiring Child Care investigatory
findings to be timely
published pres Pearson moves we Concur
and is recognize to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker this bill
requires is that child care
investigatory findings be published in a
timely manner for the house the word
timely meant not less than 21 days from
the date of the finding or decision but
the Senate changed this to read not less
than 21 business days that's the only
change that was made I ask you please to
concur the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 1507 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted chair recognizes
the clerk for a further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of the
house in the passage of the following
titled bill with amendments and the
passage of which amendments the Senate
as the concurrence of the house house
bill
1526 relative to income eligibility for
in and out medical
assistance that
we Pearson and umberger move that we
concur the chair recognizes
representative for to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker this bill in
part repeals the suspension for the
banum ending June 30
2023 which required the Department of
Health and Human Services to amend the
income eligibility standard for the
In-N-Out medical assistance policy and
it makes an appropriation of $2.7
million to do so on this the House and
Senate agree the Senate added a separate
item which revises the duties of the
executive committee established in the
mental health counseling compact
contingent upon this compact becoming
law by the passage of Senate Bill 397 I
ask you please to
concur motion before us is to concur on
House Bill
1526 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
no the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS of the house in the passage
of the following entitle bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate asked the currence of the
house house bill
1604 including State medical facilities
in the statute providing medical freedom
inations and relative to The Lure of
case managed service
providers that we Senator Pearson and
umberg move we concur chair recognizes
representative pearon to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker this bill
requires State hospitals and medical
facilities to Grant religious and
medical exemptions from vaccination
requirements provided that any requests
for medical exemption shall include the
supporting documentation required by
federal law the Senate includes case
management agencies into the definition
of Home Health Care Providers licensed
as health facilities I ask you please to
concur motion before us is occur in
House Bill 16004 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs of the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment and the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask a concurrence
of the house house bill 16 6 relative to
administration of the state immunization
registry pres Pearson moves that we
concur in is recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr
Speaker this bill makes the state
immunization registry an optin program
rather than an opt out one the Senate
version adds that a patient's personal
data shall not be entered into the
regist R without the patient's explicit
consent the amendment requires that the
optin only request needs to be done but
once per individual provider and not
every time a person sees that provider I
ask you please to
concur motion before us is to concur
when House Bill 16006 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oos
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs of the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house cacr 21 relating to
registers of probate providing that
eliminating the office of register of
probate and all references to such
office Senor Gordon moves we concurrent
is recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
c21 is a bill that proposes that a
question be put on the November ballot
as to whether the elected position of
register or probate be deleted from the
state
constitution the amendment uh adds a
second reference to the registers prob
probate which was not included in the
house version which we passed this is an
improvement to the bill and we request
that you
concur
the motion before us is to concur on
cacr 21 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay no the eyes have it the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs to the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill
481 establishing the office of the right
to know ombudsman and making an
appropriation therefore Gordon and
umberg move that we concur sen of Gordon
and umberger move we concur pres Gordon
is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 481 FN this bill
creates the office of a right to know
ombudsman the if the Ombudsman makes a
ruling his ruling can be appealed to the
Superior Court the amendment changes the
appeal to the superior court from a
denovo hearing a brand new hearing to a
hearing on issues of law only this will
make the rulings of the Ombudsman more
decisive we believe this is an
improvement to the bill and request you
to
concur motion before us is to Cur on
House Bill 481 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for a further Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1021 prohibiting certain zoning
regulation of land or structures used
primarily for religious
purposes Senator Gordon moves that we
concurrent is recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker this bill
exempts property from being excluded
from zoning districts based solely on
its used for religious purposes the
Senate Amendment deletes the
introductory statements of findings and
purpose and it adds the qualifying word
primarily for to religious purposes we
believe that this is an improvement to
the bill and request you to
concur motion before us is House Bill
1421 is to
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs at the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
of amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1195 relative to public comment periods
at school district meetings and meetings
of the State Board of
Education resident Gordon moves that we
non Concur and is recognized to speak to
his
motion
House Bill 1195 uh requires that a
public comment period at a com a public
comment period be held at school
district and uh also at um Board of
Education State Board of Education
meetings we already passed an identical
bill Senate Bill 410 that was passed by
the house a week ago on the consent
calendar
with the exact same language that's
proposed by the senate in this bill
there's no need to pass this redundant
bill and we simply ask you to non-c
concur thank you motion before us is a
non-c concur on House Bill
1195 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
no the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes a clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with the Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1343 allowing limited legal services to
be provided by certain PA of
professionals
Gord representative Gordon moves have we
concur is recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker this bill
creates a two-year pilot program in
three courts whereby qualified
non-attorney par professionals can
provide representation to litigants in
certain circuit court cases the
amendment by the Senate requires the
Supreme Court to provide a report at the
end of the pilot period it adds a third
Court Franklin to the pilot it changes
the time frame of the pilot to make sure
it will include a full two years and it
excludes non-attorney representation in
criminal cases we believe that this is
an improvement to the bill and ask you
to
concur
motion before us is the concurr on house
build
1343 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes a clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following titled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked concurr to
the house house bill
1448 relative to the pretermitted hair
statute air
statute sen of Gordon mov that we Concur
and is recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr
Speaker this bill addresses the probate
issue of pretermitted
airs generally that means children who
are unintentionally emitted from estate
planning documents such as a child born
after a will was
executed the only amendment was to
correct an error in a reference to a
prior or prior paragraphs in the bill
there's no substantive change to the
bill and we ask you to
concur the motion before us is to Cur on
House Bill
1448 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it the motion is adopted
chair recogniz the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following titled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate asks the concurrence of the house
house bill
1579 relative to landowner liability on
land authorized for outdoor recreational
activities
Gord Gordon moves we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker this bill
has to do with exempting land owners
from liability when they make their
property available without charge to the
public for recreational use the purpose
of the bill is to enable the use of
railroad rways for recreational
Trails the amendment simply adds the
words for a nominal fee to one section
of the bill which applies to leases
which are exempt from being considered a
charge this is an improvement to the
bill and we ask you to
concur motion before us is to ur on
House Bill 1579 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted the chair recognizes
the clerk for a further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
titled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate as
a concurrence to the house house bill
1597 permitting arraignments for felony
and preliminary examinations to be heard
in Circuit
Court sen Gordon moves we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker this bill
reverses legislation which we passed
back in
2015 it puts felony arraignments back in
the circuit court and assures that every
felony defendant is entitled to a
probable cause hearing
there were two amendments by the Senate
one simply makes procedural changes
consistent with current Court practices
the second postpones the implementation
date to January
2024 in order to allow the court time to
consider staffing needs during the 2023
budget cycle we encourage you to concur
with the Senate amendments thank
you motion before us has occur on House
Bill 1597 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppos
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS of the house in the passage
of the following entitled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill
1269 relative to certain legislative
study committees representative green
wec representative green moves at we
concurrent is recognized to speak to
motion thank you Mr Speaker this was a
very complex bill with over 30 sections
and the Senate changed only one item the
current law stands on the marine
fisheries committee that all members
must reside in the Tidewater coastal
towns the committee in the house had
changed that to a majority of the
members were to be residents of those
communities the Senate removed the word
majority in order to keep the status quo
and we have decided not to jeopardize
the entire bill just for this so I ask
for your
concurrence the motion before assistant
Cur and House Bill 1269 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose nay no the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted chair
recognizes the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate URS
of the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage which amendment the Senate
ask courage to of the house house bill
1277 relative to the reporting of cyber
security incidents represent Dolan
moves represent Dolan moves we Concur
and is recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr
Speaker uh House Bill 1277 was voted out
of committee at 19 to Z and uh but the
real Genesis of this bill came from
Peterboro where they suffered a
significant breach of security uh so
that's what that's where this came from
the Senate made only non consequential
changes and I urge you to vote to
concur the motion before us is the Cur
on House Bill 1277 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask the concurrence
of the house has built 1038 naming a
bridge in londondary in honor of Robert
J prow and a bridge in Portsmouth in
honor of Staff Sergeant Jessie E
Cheryl sen Gran moves we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his motion thank
you Mr Speaker the original bill um
simply named a l uh bridge in londondary
for Robert PR the Senate Amendment names
a bridge in Portsmith for staff sergeant
Jesse
isrel um who was a state Troop who was
killed when his Cruiser was hit by a
tractor trailer while on duty I and the
committee ask that you concur with the
Senate and honoring staff sergeant
cherelle the motion before us is to Cur
on House Bill
1038 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
for a further Senate message Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs of the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment which amendment the
Senate as a concurr of the house house
bill 1040 establishing a commission to
study re Revenue alternatives to the
road toll for the funding of
improvements to the state's highways and
bridges and the resulting improvements
to the
environment Z gr moves we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his motion thank
you Mr Speaker this bill establishes a
study commission to look at alternative
sources to the road toll I.E the gas tax
the focus will be on electric and other
alternative fuel vehicles the Senate
Amendment no surprise reduce the number
of senators from two to
[Music]
one hey they left what um added an
appointment to the commission by the
Governor from an energy or
Transportation
nonprofit and an added a requirement to
S might be possible to include out of
state vehicles uh that would not be
paying the road toll with the for those
that would be buy not buying gas here in
the state I am the majority of the
committee asked that you concur with the
Senate motion before us is the Cur and
House Bill 1040 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for a further Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate URS of the house and
the passage of the following entitled
bill with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill
1548 relating to the sale of the Lakes
Region
facility representative Grand moves we C
and is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker the bill deals with
the sale of the Lakes Region facility
and the potential requirement uh to
relocate the emergency services that are
currently on the property the house
version stated that this move if
required sh should be paid for out of
the proceeds of the sale the senate in
its Infinite Wisdom um states that the
move may be paid um
with proceeds and may be paid with arper
funds um in either case there are
ongoing discussions to use arpa funds to
pay for this move if required and it is
not going to happen until next year or
the year after anyways so knowing all of
this I ask that you concur with the the
Senate Amendment thank you motion before
us is ur on House Bill 1548 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled Bill
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1185 relative to treatment of water
contaminated with perlin
chemicals representative har moves we
concur when is recognized to speak to
his
motion thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
1185 as currently amended uh allows a
treatment plant to require testing of
Industrial and Commercial waste loads
for pasas with a residential load
exemption uh an error occurred when the
resources committee passed an amendment
which was in inadvertently replaced with
an incorrect amendment when it passed
the house the other body corrected this
error and replace the incorrect
Amendment with the resources correct
Amendment would ask for your concurrence
on this Bill thank you the motion before
us is ur in House Bill
1185 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it the motion is adopted
chair recognizes a clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs of the house and the passage of
the following entitled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate as C of the house HB 1188
establishing a committee to study ohrb
use in the state and clarifying certain
Towing
statutes sentive harb moves we
concurrent is recognized to speak to his
motion again thank you Mr Speaker 1188
uh set up a commission to study ohrv use
the other body attached a non gerain
Amendment clarifying the towing statute
consultation with the Transportation
chair of the house who concurred with
this amendment we're asking you also to
occur concur with uh HB 1188 as amended
thank you motion before assistant CER
and House Bill 1188 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted chair recognizes
the clerk for a further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of the
house in the passage of the following
titled bill with the amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill 11 excuse me 1339 relative to the
Winn pasak River Basin control
replacement fund harb
and presentive harb and ab bramy move
that we Concur and is recognized to
speak to his motion uh again thank you
Mr President Mr Speaker uh HB
1139 deals with the wi Basin
control replacement fund the amendment
by the Senate corrected language
relating to the method of apportionment
we are in agreement with that and I'd
ask a concurrence with the bill as
amended motion before assistant her and
House Bill 1339 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted chair recognizes
the clerk for further Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs at the house
in the passage of the following titled
bill with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill
1554 relative to online payment of fees
relating to the operation of off Highway
recreational vehicles and snowmobiles
and relative to Grants administered by
the Bureau of trails for ohrv trail
development and
maintenance Senator harb moves we Concur
and is recognized to speak to his motion
again thank you Mr Speaker um the other
body added an additional amendment to
this bill increasing the grant and aid
percentages uh the resources committee
is in favor of this amendment and would
ask you to concur thank you motion
before us is ur in House Bill 1554 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the motion is adopted and the
house recognizes the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following titled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concurrence of the house
house bill 169 establishing a commission
to study the removal of unused utility
polls following the transition of
equipment lines and cables to new
utility
polls sen V moves we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
169 sets up a commission to figure out
what to do with unused utility polls the
Senate added one additional member to
this commission the commissioner of the
Department of energy or design we concur
and ask that you do the same thank
you the motion before us is occur on
House Bill 169 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted house recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS with the house in the passage
of the following entitled bill with
amendments in the passage which
amendments the Senate ask concurrence to
the house house bill
543 establishing a commission to study
nuclear power and nuclear reactor
technology in New
Hampshire we V moves we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his motion thank
you Mr Speaker this bill sets up a
commission to study nuclear power in New
Hampshire the Senate added two
additional members to the commission one
the commissioner of the Department of
energy the other one is the commissioner
of the bureau Department of uh business
and economic Affairs we ask you to
concur motion before us is ur on House
Bill 5443 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs to the house in the
passage of the following title bill with
Amendment the pass of which amendment
the Senate as concur to the house house
bill 1148 relative to prohibiting
government entities subordinate to the
state from restricting the types of fuel
sources that may be used for
energy we V mov ween Curr and is
recognized to speak to his motion thank
you Mr Speaker House Bill 1148
originally prohibited municipalities
from prohibiting the use of any kinds of
fuels within their uh borders the Senate
substantially changed this bill they now
have changed it into a investigation by
the department of energy as to whether
or not M municipalities have this
Authority or need this
Authority this information will be
useful in the future so we have decided
to ask you to concur on this Senate
Amendment thank you motion before us is
to Cur on House Bill 1148 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose nay the eyes have it
the motion is adopted and the chair
recognizes the clerk for further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of
the house and the passage of the
following titled bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
ask concurrence of the house house bill
1258 relative to the implementation of
the Department of energy and relative to
the definition of Municipal host for
purpose
of limited electrical energy
producers V mov we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his motion thank
you Mr Speaker this bill was an 11 page
bill that
addressed the discrepancies between the
division of the Public Utilities
Commission into two entities one being
the department of energy by
hb2 the bill itself fixed many
discrepancies between the two to new
departments the Senate discovered a
couple of additional discrepancies and
their amendment clarifies that Ru making
by the department of energy must occur
within 5 years it removes the
legislative oversight committee
established abolished rather by HB 1270
from statute and it adds the state of
New Hampshire to the definition of
Municipal host in The Limited electrical
energy producers state statute we concur
with these changes and ask you to do the
same thank you motion before to curan
House Bill 1258 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for f the Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate as
concurrence of the house house bill
1546 enabling the commissioner of the
Department of Environmental Services to
adopt rules relative to airb born pasos
in certain
circumstances Vose moov we Concur and is
recognized to speak to his motion thank
you Mr Speaker this bill as originally
passed the
house enabled the Department of
Environmental Services to determine if
there were any studies about the air
inhalation of past
substances the Senate thought that it
would be better to put that Authority
Under the commissioner of the Department
of Environmental Services they also
thought that it would be better to rely
on the existing definition of past
that's already in statute rather than
creating another definition those are
both good changes and we concur with
them and ask you to do the same thank
you motion before us is occur on House
Bill 1546 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS of the house and the passage
of the following entitled bill of
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate askur of the house
house bill 1599 relative to customer
generators who sell renewable energy
certificates sen Vose moves we Concur
and is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker this bill as
originally passed by the
house specified that the Pu should
exclude RPS costs from net metering
tariffs in the future the Senate decided
that they would prefer to see
that the Pu wait until after the value
of distributed energy resources study
was completed it's due for completion
this spring before moving down this
path and we concur with that change and
ask you to do the same thank
you motion before us is occurrent House
Bill 1599 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recognizes a clerk for
a further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate curs of the house in the passage
of the following en titled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask to the house
house bill
1653 relative to educational employment
opportunities and protections for
military families and their dependence
and relative to Temporary licenses for
emergency and advanced emergency care
providers representative m and moves we
Concur and is recognized to speak to his
motion thank you Mr Speaker on behalf of
the chair of the house committee on
state federal relations and Veterans
Affairs I would ask that the members of
this body support the motion to concur
with the latest amended version of HB
1653 concerning educational and
employment opportunities and protections
for military families and their
dependents relative to Temporary
licenses and advance Advanced emergency
care providers the other body's amended
language improves the original measure
so we ask that this body
concur the motion before us is urrent
House Bill 1653 are ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted the chair recognizes
the clerk for further Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
titled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate as a
concurrence of the house house Bill 1160
relative to obedience to signals at
railroad
crossings sen Walsh moves who concurr
and is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker uh the Senate
amendment makes two small changes it
adds a she after a he and it changes a
no person shall to a he or she shall not
the committee on Transportation is
relieved that these egregious errors
were corrected and we ask that you
concur
the motion before is Mr Curran
1160 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted to chair recognizes a clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs of the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as concurrence of
the house house bill 11 excuse me 1474
relative to annual vehicle inspections
Walsh
nonon senat Walsh moves we non-c Concur
and is recognized to speak to his motion
yeah thank you Mr Speaker without
getting into the weeds um the Senate
Amendment actually guts the original
Bill uh what they replaced it with is
not even close to the intent that was
passed by this body uh it's also
incomplete so we ask that you non-c
concur the motion before it is the
non-concurrent house bill
1474 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
for further Senate message Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask the concurrence
of the house house bill
1097 relative to taxation of income of
New Hampshire residents when working
remotely for an outof State
employer sen bramy moves we concurrent
is recognized to speak to his
motion uh thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if you remember when
Massachusetts was in their state of
emergency there was an executive order
that said that any employee of a company
in Massachusetts that worked at home
would now be subject to income
Massachusetts income
tax if you recall also the Governor did
not like that idea and he filed
suit against Massachusetts and that
didn't go very well in the Supreme Court
which is where these kind of disputes
are are
resolved in the meantime 1097 was filed
and by the time it got to ways and means
that the state of emergency was lifted
and the uh the uh the executive order
was
rescinded so in ways the means we
decided to do like we did with Wayfair
to do a deterrence bill for the future
so we work with the a lawyer from the
AG's office and a lawyer from the
Department of Revenue where we came up
with Lang that we hoped that in the
future if this occurred Again by any
other State against us that that we
would have some protections and the very
least it would be taken up by the
Supreme
Court when we went over to the Senate
that that bill passed overwhelmingly by
partisan on this floor when I went over
to the Senate sever of our members went
over and then that testimony that
testimony turned into a conversation
where they wanted to do a few little
tweaks to the language and uh last uh
Tuesday fortunately Ways and Means was
meeting on revenues and uh we all
concurred with the revised language that
came out of the Senate thank you motion
before Cur on House Bill
1097 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those oppose nay
the the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted pres of paig and Ward declared
menance who did not vote and participate
in the
vote Jer and Isa clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house in
adoption of the amendment to the
following bill sent from the house house
bill 200 increasing the penalty for
certain invasions of privacy and
requests a committee a conference the
president on be on the part of the
Senate has appointed as members of the
said committee Senators gray burel and
Susi
pres barara Griffin moves that we aced
to the
request are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppos nay
the eyes have it the chair appoints
representative Barbara Griffin
representative Barry Lynn and
Representative Steven
Smith
chair recognizes the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house in
adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled bill sent from the
house Senate Bill 238 relative to
special education services and chartered
public schools and requests a committee
of conference the president on the part
of the Senate has appointed as members
of said committee Senators Ward ricardi
and
Prentice
Vlad sen Vlad moves we acceed to the
Senate message are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those propose nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted chair appoints
representative lad cordelli Hobson and
Tanner to the committee of
conference chair recogniz the clerk for
a further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
and the adoption of the amendment to the
following title bill sent from the
house Senate Bill 271 relative to the
Burgess biopower facility and requested
Committee of conference the president on
the part of the Senate has appointed as
members of said committee Senators avar
Bradley and Waters
represented Vose moves we aced to the
request are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted the chair appoints
representative V Thomas Harington and
McGee
chair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house in the
adoption of the amendment to the
following titled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 301 establishing the
office of right to no Ombudsman and
making an appropriation therefore and
request a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said committee
Senators Carson French and
Khan sen Gordon moves we a seed to the
request are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair appoints representative
Gordon walper D Lorenzo and
McGee
mle the Senate refuses to concur with
the house in the adoption of the
amendment to the following titled bill
sent from the house Senate Bill 302
establishing the personal privacy
protection act in request a committee of
conference president on the part of the
Senate has appointed as members of s
committee Senators Carson French and
Whitley
EXC sen Gordon moves we acceed to the
Senate message are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the chair appoints
representative Gordon McLean walper and
Sylvia
chair recogniz clerk for further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to
concur
with the amendment to the following
titled bill Senate from the house Senate
Bill 313 relative to the authority of
the office of the professional lenser
and certification to establish fees and
requests a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said committee
Senators G Carson and
Rosenwald moves that
weed McGuire moves that we acceed are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the motion is adopted the chair
appoints representative McGuire abrami
Shu and Steve
Pearson chair recognizes the clerk for
fing the Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following title bill sent from the house
Senate Bill 353 relative to education
Professional Standards Board and request
a committee of conference the president
on the part of the Senate has appointed
as members of said committee Senators
Ward ricardian
Apprentice
laded pres vad moves we acceed are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I those opposed A the eyes
have it the motion is adopted the chair
appoints representative vad cordelli
Ford and
Miler J recognize the clerk for further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house in the
adoption of the amendment to the
following title bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 358 relative to the
Joint legislative committee on
administrative rules and request the
committee of conference the president on
the part of the Senate has appointed as
members of said committee Senators
Reagan Carson and
Kavanaugh Mr Maguire moves we aced are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the motion is adopted the chair
appoints representative McGuire goalie
algro and
scitech chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following titled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 366 requiring an audit
of the ballots cast in the 2022 Primary
in general election and requests a
committee of conference the president on
the part of the Senate has appointed as
members of said committee Senators gray
berzel and
Susi
Griffin exceed
Mr Barbara Griffin moves that we concur
exed exed are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the chair
appoints representative Barbara Griffin
McDonald berson and
qua chair recogniz the clerk for further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house and the
adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled Bill sen up from the
house Senate Bill 38 1 establishing an
office of the advocate for special
education and request a committee of
conference president on the part of the
Senate has appointed as members of said
committee Senators Ward Hennessy
Apprentice pres Vlad moves that we aced
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppos a guys have
it the motion is adopted the chair
appoints representative lad cordelli
Hobson and
Lichfield J recognizes the clerk for
further Senate Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house in the
adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 401 making
Appropriations to the Department of
Transportation for local Highway Aid
into the body worn and dashboard camera
fund permitting the Department of
Transportation to operate dash cameras
and fleet vehicles and relative to the
duration of unemployment benefits and
request a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed his members of said committee
Senators Bradley Daniels and
Rosenwald moves
weed of abis moves we aced are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppos nay eyes have it and the
motion is adopted chair appoints
representative Roy abbis umberger and
wer J recognizes the clerk for further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house in the
adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 420 establishing an
extraordinary need grant for schools and
relative to eligibility for the
education tax credit and request a
committee of conference the president on
the part of the Senate has appointed as
members of said committee Senators Ward
Hennessy and Apprentice
lab sen lab moves we aced are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
why those oppos nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the chair appoints
representative lad
cordelli
wer and
luno G recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 445 relative to the
Broadband matching Grant initiative and
request a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate as
appointed as members of the set
committee Senators Hennessy Bradley and
Khan moves we
exceed s unber moves we exceed are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the motion is adopted chair
appoints representative Emerich Griffin
Mooney and
leechman that's Gerald
Griffin J recognizes the clerk for
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house in the
adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled bill Senate from the
House of Representatives Senate Bill 458
relative to the sununu Youth Services
Center in operation of a replacement
secure facility and request a committee
of conference the president on the part
of the Senate has appointed as members
of Z committee Senators Carson Bradley
and
Rosenwald representative rice
anded and a rice and hurger mov a seed
are you ready for the question all all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
eyes have it the motion is adopted chair
appoints representative rice D Simone
Earth and
walner chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative osor for the
motion to adjourn from the early session
the question is on a motion to adjourn
from the early session are ready for the
question all
those all right hey resolved that the
house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
and when the house adjourns today it be
to meet Thursday Mark May 26th at 10:
a.m. the moot the motion before is
adjourned from the early session you're
ready for the
question I would ask everybody stay in
their seats we have a
very important unanimous consent coming
before us that has to do with veterans
so please everybody remain in their
seats are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose
nay and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes representative
long for an announcement Lang
Lang thank you Mr Speaker I promise the
last time I'm going to talk about
softball so softball this Saturday the
22nd or Sunday the 22nd at 2:00 at the
marac anheiser bush plant um so we have
two team leads uh representative by
representative Vose and representative
magori I've been listening to some smack
talk from both of them um apparently uh
representative Maori says that he's
going to give the Republicans a preview
of what's going to look like in November
when we lose and representative V says
that he's when we win the Democrats
going to become so mad they're going to
turn red so uh I urge everyone to show
up uh have a good time we have practice
today immediately following a hour after
session um we'll be having a bipartisan
practice and then there'll be another
bipartisan practice on Sunday the 15th
at 2m it's at Reeds field um we have a
representative shamberg over there has
agreed to be a umpire and we have
representative B over here is going to
be an Umpire so we should have some fun
with some strikes and balls so uh hope
everybody shows up have a good time
thank you guys for an
announcement chair recognizes the clerk
for announcement thank you Mr Speaker
just a couple of quick announcements one
the class photo shoot is going to be on
Thursday May 26 at 9:30 in front of the
state house so please be here by 20 past
if you could so that we can take a class
photo uh promptly at 9:30 um knowing uh
the membership as we do uh it will take
a few minutes uh to get you all
assembled uh at 9:40 the staff will be
assembling so we have 10 minutes to get
it right folks uh next announcement um
again uh there are antigen tests
available in the anti- room in your
mailboxes if you would like to use them
please take them home for our last
session or uh you can um deposit them in
the uh receptacle in the back thank you
Mr
Speaker
CH recognizes representative Roy and
shirtliff for unanimous
consent Miss oh you come why don't you
come on why don't you come on around and
you both can be at the okay not in front
behind
[Applause]
thank you colleagues I promise to take
as little of your time as I can on this
beautiful day we are today we're doing a
unanimous consent and recognition of
homeless veterans in within our
state we as a body have had a tough time
coming together on a lot of things but
one thing we've always come together on
is taking care of our veterans um two
years ago when we were in a Democrat
majority I introduced a bill to assist
veterans uh disabled veterans with uh
their children for school and that past
this year in the Republican majority we
improved that bill and it passed we work
together when we take care of our
veterans homelessness in general is an
embarrassment to our
society homelessness to Veterans even
more so and I'll explain
why um when earlier when we have the
privileg of hearing U Le PESA speak it
brought back a lot of memories for me I
was stationed in West Germany when he
was actually going through his troubles
at the time and as I recall um the
Soviet military at the time scrambled to
to try and crush the Rebellion that was
going on in Poland
and we in response to that also had the
scramble and we had numerous alerts and
3 in the morning we'd be called to the
border and get down there with our tanks
just in case they crossed and it was it
brought back a lot of good memories too
in the Hamshire we have almost a 100,000
veterans that's a lot for the size of
our state we are eighth in the United
States for the number of veterans per
capita we are a patriotic and serving
state and we have a owe a debt of
gratitude to those folks and I'll
explain why every veteran when they sign
up for the military they write a check
it's payable to each and every one of
you and that check is a blank and it's
payable with their
life now many of them most of them
thankfully don't ever have to have that
check cashed at the end of this month
we'll be celebrating Memorial Day and
that's for the folks whose checks we
cashed
but the rest of us I don't know about
you you ever pay a bill and you write a
check and somebody just doesn't goad and
cash it it drives you nuts because you
have to keep carrying that over in your
in your Ledger every month well the
veterans that we have out there now
those checks are still out there and we
have no way of paying it back I don't
know what someone's life's worth and I
don't want to try and put a value on
it but for the homeless
veterans there's a lot more we could
do there are numerous programs to help
them but the problem is a lot of them
come back from service and they're
damaged they have mental illness
physical
illnesses and it's hard to get in touch
and figure out ways to be helped when no
one knows how to reach you when you
don't know how to reach anybody
else military teaches us to operate as a
team when you get out of the military
you lose that team you're on your own
and it's very difficult for some
especially in combat arms whose training
training was solely on how to kill the
enemy to fit back into society and find
a useful way to contribute and be a
member and a lot of times they end up on
the outskirts of our society and it's
our job to reach in and find them not
for them to find
us so right now we know of at least 120
homeless veterans in this state that's
120 people that are sleeping outside now
a lot of people forget about the
homeless when the weather gets nice like
this but it has a lot more to do than
just the weather imagine not having a
place to sleep not having a phone not
having someone to help you with your
doctor's appointments your medication
your food there's a lot of things that
go along with that
roof so on this Memorial Day and in this
month which is um military um
recognition of veterans this month keep
it in mind every time you pass a
homeless
person first of all we need to help all
the homeless but they could be a veteran
and we still like they still have that
check outstanding that we need to
fulfill and uh in closing I would just
also like to ask everyone why you're
keeping the veterans in mind and keeping
the homeless of mind and we work
together I commit next session that if
God willing I'm here I'm happy to
co-sponsor with anyone from any party
any legislation to help the
veterans but also in the meantime if you
can afford it um think about donating
some formula to your local shelter
because there's babies that are running
out of food right now and with that I
would like to turn it over to my
esteemed former Speaker of the House
Representative Sheriff thank
[Applause]
you walking across the bridge and
standing briefly at the speaker Podium
reminded me that I've almost gone two
years now in this session without one
said saying let me tell you a story so
let me tell you a
story in June of
1815 um Wellington defeated Napoleon at
the Battle of
waterl in the Duke of Wellington and the
men who fought under him at woo became
national heroes in England and the
British government had a metal Struck it
was the
watero uh Memorial
medal and it was given to every man that
fought in that battle it's it was a
silver medal with blue and red ribbon
attached to it and it was the Victory
Medal and they tell the story about an
old man a homeless man in the 1840s in
London who was arrested by the London
Police for being a
vagrant and they took him to the Old
Bailey to appear before a
magistrate and the magistrate in his
black robe and his hus hair wig looked
at
down literally and figuratively at
this man and he's standing before him in
these
rags and he said in somewhat of a
disgusted
and voice he said to this man can you
give me any reason why I should not send
in you to the
workhouse and the old man reached into
the lining of his torn
jacket and he grabbed this piece of
tonish silver metal with some red and
blue threads hanging from
it and the old man standing a little
taller and with
a deep and resounding voice held out his
Mir his water Victory
Medal no matter how tough life had been
to that old man no matter how much he
suffered the one thing he would never
part with was his waterl Victory Medal
it meant more to him than life itself
and he said to the magistrate your
worship I have about one thing to
say he said I was with Wellington at
watero and with that the magistrate teed
up banged his gavel and said this trag
against this man are
dismissed and I think about that story
and realize in the past almost 200 years
conditions for our veterans our homeless
and those being challenged haven't
changed all that
much and so this month we celebrate the
celebration of our members of the Armed
Forces and I hope Us in the granite
state like we've done for so many
worthwhile causes will now again this
year stand up and help our brothers and
sisters who are homeless and facing
other challenges many with mental
illness
and some of that mental illness would
not have happened to him if not for the
experience in the armed
forces so let us celebrate this month
celebrate our men and women but most of
all keep in our hearts our brothers and
sisters who have stood up for us and
served our country and do all we can for
them thank you Mr
[Applause]
Speaker
before we go on to the next
one
yeah could I I have
all those that are either currently
serving or have served in the military
please stand
[Applause]
up please please keep standing please
every everyone that has served please
keep
standing we have with us in the
gallery Major General melodus and Deputy
adant General Warren Perry and staff
members of
[Applause]
the and staff members of the division of
community-based military programs who
work on programs to end veteran
homelessness in New Hampshire we also
have representatives of other veterans
organizations and service organizations
with us please stand and be recognized
and let us thank you for all that you do
on this important
[Applause]
issue
without objection the remarks of both
the speakers will be printed in the
permanent
Journal
the chair recognizes representative
Tanner for unanimous
consent thank you Mr
Speaker um something very important
happened last weekend and I wanted to
talk about it um a small rural Town cyen
New Hampshire and my district um that
has retained the traditional town and
school meeting format since
1793 uh which tends to be the New
England tradition of pure democracy one
person one vote um this year they had
their meeting scheduled on a Saturday in
April and I'm sure most of you will
remember that Saturday um it was a day
we had an April unusual April snowstorm
it was like a heavy Squall that lasted
from about 900 in the morning till noon
they only had 34 citizens show up to
that school meeting um and that they
braved the weather and came um to that
school meeting to vote on the
budget uh it was a perfect storm and for
an unexpected and very unpopular motion
to be made that cut that school budget
by
50% the motion passed with a vote of 20
to
14 as word spread many residents
including especially the parents of
croon students many of whom were not at
the meeting were very shocked and angry
the new budget would not support tuition
payments for their children to attend
the nearby local
school the school was pushing an online
micro
School the member needs a suspend who is
the member who withdrew
consent who withdrew consent speak
representative representative consent
v a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently
seconded it is officially seconded this
will be a roll call
vote
e
the motion before us is to withdraw
consent continue or and shall the member
continue
speaking this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
Representatives was here in
11 I need your thumb
please
[Music]
for all members president an opportunity
to
vote CH recognize
vote 206 voting y 52 voting
a the member will
continue thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you to the body for voting to allow this
to go on um so the the vote cut the
school budget by
50% and um the school board was pushing
online micros schools and homeschooling
If the parents wanted their child to go
to the public school they would have to
pay thousands of dollars in the meantime
members of the town uh minority group
included their elected officials who
proposed cut the cut um celebrated their
victory of dismantling public
education uh the town's people found in
statute one chance to reverse the
DraStic cut to the school budget it was
a high bar at least 50% of the towns
registered voters had to attend a
special meeting and vote on the original
budget they needed to organize educate
and reach out to voters about their
shared goals and values uh for educating
their youth they needed to let the
residents of the Town know that not all
their fellow citizens or elected
officials shared their commitment to the
community and education of their
children the law required that about
that 283 people 50% of the registered
voters had to show up at that special
meeting and a majority had to support
the
budget I had the privilege this last
Saturday to see democracy in action
typically the meetings in cuden draw
only about 10% of the registered voters
on May 7th even without a snowstorm on
May 7th the date for the special meeting
60% of them showed up I watched
379 people file into the lar largest
Hall they could find in the community
which was a camp dining hall and I saw
them very organized and getting their
ballots I heard parents students talking
about standing up fighting back against
those who trying to change their
Community they talked about how covid
had affected their children by isolating
them from the interaction in classrooms
with teachers and the many problems they
had online learning including getting
and keeping a con internet connection
it's very rural a young man
talked about how his parents were both
working parents and didn't have the
money to send him to the public school
that he hadd been looking forward to his
senior year uh he looked forward to
working with his teachers that he
completing his welding program at the
CTE um he said getting dressed to the
nines for the prom experiencing that
final year with his friends
participating in sports and
co-curricular activities
having a formal graduation getting ready
for a career or college and having the
shared experience that the generations
before him had the privilege of having
then came the vote
377-2 it was followed by the celebration
of those who had worked so
hard um it is a wakeup call for all of
us in New Hampshire to show up get
involved debate the issues know your
candidate Ates that will represent you
not their ideological positions and then
vote political decisions should
represent the consent of the Govern not
the power of a few if we want to keep
our state our country our democracy we
need to stand up for our local state and
federal government the future of our
community our Public Schools our state
is hanging at a Tipping Point please use
your voice and your vote and keep our
Dem democracy thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you what reason to member rise Mr
Speaker I move that the remarks of the
previous speaker be added to the
permanent
journal without
consent without objection I
meant the mo the motion is to print the
remarks in the permanent
Journal are you ready for the
vote roll call has been requested is
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote
the motion before us is print the
remarks of the last unanimous consent in
the permanent Journal this is going to
be a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press agree button if you're
oppos to press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
all members present and an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 184 voting
yay 70 voting nay remarks will be
printed
chair recognize the represent Branch for
unanimous
consent we still have business to
conclude so don't go running
off thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise today from my second to last
unanimous consent speech to answer a
question I've been asked multiple times
today am I running again the answer
sadly to that question is no sadly it
has become unaffordable to continue
living in Amherst after the end of this
term I have loved my time in this house
and I love the work that we do I have
learned so much and met so many
wonderful
people I would like to thank a few of
them specifically first first I'd like
to thank the chair of my committee state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
the member from Londoner who is also not
running again he has served this house
for the past 16 years and has run our
committee with fairness and respect I
believe our committee is a shining
example of how politics and committees
should be we can disagree without being
disagreeable and we can get a lot done
while working
together with that I would like to thank
the member from London D who sadly is
not here today not only for his service
to this house but the service to our
country I'd also like to thank my
ranking member the member from Littleton
who has been like a mother to me in this
house she has offered guidance and
advice not that I always followed it but
she is always someone I can count on and
she also makes delicious
fudge which she loves to share with
fellow members of our
committee next I would like to thank the
fellow independent in this house the
member from New
Market for becoming one of my best
friends during my time here in the house
although we only really got to know each
other this year she has always been
there for me there are countless others
I would like to thank but I'd be here
all night finally I would like to thank
the 199 members of this house who voted
to allow me to speak and shine line on
the issues facing our state thank
you
thank you all for a wonderful term and
remember that everybody here has a story
and there is a lot more than just party
affiliation get to know members on both
sides of the aisle and remember you can
disagree without being disagreeable
thank
[Applause]
you
representative urn Osborne moves at the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills and roll build
amendments rooll build reports and
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and a
motion is adopted the house is in recess
till Thursday May 26th 20122 at 10:
a.m.